the entire border crossing took us 12
hours,
I don’t know, it seems to me that the
Russian border guards somehow slowly let us through.
That is, for example, yesterday before 12 pm
it was possible to pass much faster
after 12 pm somehow or a lot of cars
arrived Or they began to work worse and
slower
if we analyze the mobilization, then
my friends seem to be unsuitable for age
Well, at least then the mobilization
that is going on now, we don’t know what
will happen next naturally, but at the moment
a lot of people apparently want to go
abroad and add up such a mess,
a lot of cars there  as I understand it, I
just arrived at 5 in the morning about
two kilometers,
I don’t even know how many people didn’t watch,
but the traffic was slow
[music]
mobilization was inevitable because there weren’t
enough human resources,
it doesn’t bother me because I’m already
59 years old and  my son Lives abroad
Well, all
formations about some kind of hype at airports and
so on She is very much exaggerated
och  it is greatly exaggerated,
and so on, a lot of
fake information appears on this subject
, so here you need to be very
careful
not to become victims of simply
false information